To make it easy to sychronise
the audio and video later.
Except... that's not really an
answer to the question, is it?
If the question was "why do YouTubers
clap at the start of their recordings",
then yes, that's the answer,
it's to help with synchronisation.
A lot of the time, audio and video
are being recorded separately.
The microphone on my collar
is sending its signal
to a small and very beaten-up recorder
that's clipped to my back pocket.
The camera is recording its own sound too,
and saving that as part of the video file
on its memory card,
[muffled, through camera mic]
but it sounds terrbile.
[back to main microphone]
So when I'm working on the edit
and putting the two files back together,
it's really useful to have
a short, loud, impulse sound
at the start of both files,
so I can synchronise them just by
looking for the spike on the display.
There's a couple of extra complications
there, though.
First of all:
should that synchronisation be perfect?
That camera is about two metres
away from me.
The speed of sound changes
a little with temperature,
but roughly, that's about
6 or 7 milliseconds.
Not enough to care about here,
but once you start putting
the camera further away,
ten or twenty metres for long shots...
that sound can take a couple of frames
to reach the camera and the audience.
That would feel weird,
so I'd have to slip the audio a little.
That's why it's worth double-checking
the synchronisation by looking
for the frame of video
where the hands touch.
Plus, some cameras,
particularly old GoPros,
actually add some sound delay
to the video file,
their synchronisation is terrible.
So if I've got three, or ten,
or a hundred different cameras
all looking at the same thing,
I can use that clap to
synchronise them all:
get it close by looking
for the spike,
confirm it by looking
at the hands.
Actually, worst case, the audio can
actually be late by up to...
maybe three frames or so?
And the chances are no-one
will mind or even notice.
Actually, the sound on this video
has been three frames late
ever since I cut back
to this shot of me?
If you did actually notice, well done,
I'll put it back to normal now.
I suspect that works because brains
are used to correcting for
small speed-of-sound lags for
people shouting from a distance,
but that's just speculation,
I can't find research to back that up.
And because the viewer might have things
like a cheap external soundbar
on a television that adds more lag,
it's best to synchronise
as close as you can.
If the production's got a high budget,
they might use a clapperboard instead.
That means the editor
has a record of which file
is which take of which scene,
at the start,
and they can sync up the audio
at the same time.
But all that is still not
an answer to the question.
It's the answer everyone gives,
but it's not what the title of
this video is actually asking.
This isn't "why do YouTubers clap
at the start of recordings",
it's "why do YouTubers clap
at the start of videos".
I've done that plenty of times before.
I did it in this video.
Why do we leave a bit of
technical junk in the video?
Why do I set up a really nice shot
and then ruin it
by showing the setup part,
letting my camera fuzz about with autofocus,
and make the whole video... worse?
Well, I can't speak for everyone,
but my reason is:
it sets the audience's expectations,
and it makes it feel more authentic.
When I'm filming on my own
with a static camera,
it can sometimes look like I'm
just stood against a green-screen.
But clapping, walking into frame,
letting the focus settle,
showing that behind-the-scenes moment...
it proves I'm here,
it makes me seem more trustworthy.
For someone vlogging from their bedroom,
keeping those claps and the preparation in,
letting the audience see a little bit
of the slip-ups and how it's made...
it helps make a connection,
helps make them relatable.
I don't need to be relatable.
I don't really want to be relatable?
But trustworthy.
Trustworthy is good,
and leaving the clap and walk in the video
establishes that I'm
one person with one camera,
that I don't have a crew on this shoot,
and that I am actually here,
wherever here is.
Sometimes I'll leave that in
when I actually do have a crew.
It's all about the aesthetics.
Showing that setup,
leaving that synchronisation clap in,
it's all about fitting
the message to the medium,
planning not just what you want to say,
but the subtext of how you say it,
and handling all the subtle cues
that connect performer to audience
and say, it's okay.
You can trust me.